N GOES
FROM HERE, AHEAD.
M KE TPE ON WHEREHE
OU TD. AMERICANS ARE W
RMANCES, HOLIDAY SCHOOLY,  COVU
HOSPITALIZATIONS ATHS
ESPECIALLY HITTING THE
UN
WASHINGTON,
D.C.THORO F H CASES AND  AR
MONTH D.E WORL ERCID
BOOSTERS AS TH
SERIOUS ILLNESS.PREV
EAL WEAKNESSES IOURTH WAVE IS
DEALT WITE
VIRUS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO TESTING
THOUGHT WE WOULDYEAR AGO
WHEN BIDENEDIS
2021 MIGHT FORMAL.
CLOSE TOHA
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE BUT I
THMAS CLOSTO
>> JDICAL
ADR  BIDEN, DR
DR TING US.CI.
IF YOU COULD GO BACKENELINT
EFFORT TTHE WORLSOLL HWENER MULO
OP MUTATIONS?
WE NEETO THE
WITH FREE AT-HOME RAPISTING? NE
ALLIES AS LE T
WE
VIRUS IN JULY EVEN IF THINGS
WELL, I SAY
OF THE.
THEAG ANNG
AN ASPIRATION TO THE VIRUS A
E ONE S UNDERSTANDABLE AND
E KNOW FW ALMOST TWO
YEARS' ENCE WITH THIS
VIRUS TH REALL
COUNTRY AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD, FIRST AN
OMICRON.
Y IS SOMETHING THAT IS
UNPRECEN E TERMS T ERON
CORATION TRTAIN YOU'RE NOT AND N
PUTTING ALL YOURESUDG
PEOPLED  WD
TESE WHEU OMICRO PROTECTION FROM
A TW mRNE IS QUITEY AGAIT VEDIS
OMICROHE PROTECTION  DIST
ME RIGHT BACK UP
HEWH
PART
DAESAYE EN SAYING IT
CE OBOOSTED,
IN WITH
TS WHY  PPLY D NOW JUSTD AS FUY
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
DENIO WHEN PEOPLE ARHAS THAT
AF
BOOSTER BUT THE MI
HASN'T GONE .SHOULD
>>N RESPET IS SEMANT F AAKE
TOE OPLLPROTECTED,
BUT IF LOOK AT I SITUATION THA Y
Y WHEN AM LLTHERE'S DTH'STE>>
JUST A'M JAKE,OT
"L.A. TIMES" THIS WEEK THAT THEE
"W DELTA COMING.
K MOST SCITIS STOOD ON
WHCE ANDRO
RELIED O SEE D
COMING, DIDN'T SEE O
OBSLTHE SPECIFICANTO
L LOOK
GENERAL SEE E  COMING?
>>E W
SAW VARIANTS COMING.I INERD S
ANTICIPATED WAE EXTENT UTATIONS
WHICH ISLLUNPRECEDENTEIND AMT OW
AIRUS 5ON  REALLY QUITE PRECED
SOMETHING YOU WOULD NO
WERE ANTIPHE BUT WE CERTAINLY
WHEN YOU HAVSOVIRUS, SLI GOING E
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY TO G TO
MAE                AN
TATIONS WINDP BEING A
T.
ASHEES SPIKILY WHAT HAPPENED  CT
AMERARE STG
LINES, MANY PHMAOLD T OF RT-HOMN
PEHE IDE TESTS TO EVER
AMERICAN.
IS THE STATE OF TESTED STATEO Y?
>> WELL, WE GO DBETTER IF
NOMPE WE WERA
YEAR AGO, IT'SRENT IN THE POSITE
S E
D NONE A YWE TO DOETTER.
THE GOVEHE FEDERAL BINVESTING N
MAKE ANYERFR200 MILLION
A MONTH.RS WILT FREESOE'RE GOIN
TO BE GOINIG
DIRECTION.
AND I'VED  MYSELE,HA R
TO FLOOD THE SYS
TESTIN
GOING TO BIN WHOTS THE WHEN WE'
THOUGH TVACCIN
OSHEY MA TA MILE
W N
COMING INTO THE ORSOMEPLACE THAE
POSITIVE.IDENE VACCINAT AAT
DEATH.SAIDAL ERE ILLSS
BLNG.
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND WELL,, JAK
SIGNIFICANT STRESS IRERY ON THEL
THOSE AREAS WHERE YOU HAVEVEL O
NT TF GETTING THE
VACCINATE VACCINATED
THIS VIRUS IEXTRAORDINARY.
GOERYOLOOK AT WHATN SOUTH , WHA
O DO
NOW, PRESIDENT I
I MEAN, I WAS WITH HIM WHEN HE
ID THAT, AND I SPOKE TO HI
AB, ATG TO
DIFFICULTIES RIGHT NOW, ANWE
BETTER BREGATE
T THATAND IT'S NEV
, AND IF RECINATED, GO GET
BOAND BENT IN
EVERYTHING ELSE YOU ,
THRE CA
MA'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
JA CWITH
OMICRON, THAT WE'RE DEALING
, G TO BE A TOUGH
E GE
>> FOR INDIVLSRE AND, WHAT
SUPPOSED TO DO?OOE
TEACHERAR
I MEAN SAW INTENSE E TONA PSYCH.
WHAT ARE YOU
>> WELL, RIGHT NOW
THE CHILDREN IN SC SAFELY,
LIO  THE CDC CAME OUT WITHE
WAS TOT TOTA
WHERE IT DOERKE IF YOU A IN A
SCHOOL, RAERHAVING TR
CHILDREN OF TEST THE CHIN ARE NB
POHE SCHOOLS
REASONST YOU JUST GAVTLY OF T